alors en 60 secondes vous devez sortir
il va trouver quelqu'un échangez vos
chaussures avec lui familles et revenir
avec les chaussures de la personne 60
secondes c'est parti pour 5 100 euros
c'est parti allez hop tu peux te prendre
des chaussettes
c'est hyper important c'est pour eux
même toit quand le temps le temps qu
aller il est là on va voir maman a pris
feu ce qui vient 500 vous regarde
comment ça se passe quand une autre
passe au tessin selon lui se passe bien
allez aimer l'om et là tout est non oui
bon c'est sympa ça passe
combien de temps découverte de temps
après celle à battre avec des chaussures
du monsieur à merde sur du monsieur tu
me dis après sa baisse de débit
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
combien de temps va second à 20 secondes
à agacer
car selon ses gardiens pour maintiendra
[Applaudissements]
pour cent cinquante ont tu vas devoir et
quelqu'un va devoir relever le défi de
la tête du pâtissier dacquois la tête du
pâtissier c'est-à-dire convaincre une
personne de vous casser deux jeux et de
la farine sur la tête 60 secondes vas-y
jamais rien zéro pas des gens me appelez
vite on laissera cinq secondes de plus
il n'a pas traîné mademoiselle gens
subissent pour faire gagner de l'argent
aux téléspectateurs quelques longueurs
vous me cassez les deux sur la tête ils
mettaient à farine après votre sac mais
castrés 2 allait gagner d'autres mais
pour mon plus grand d'asie
beurk
il est très fort et il est très fort
jean michel basset c'est un petit truc
mais c'est pas mal c'est pour 20 euros
allez faire un câlin à une personne sans
lui parler rester au moins 10 secondes
dans ses bras c'est le free hugs tu
choisis qui il avait le minimum ah ouais
c'est bon elle a 60 secondes vous voyez
pas quelqu'un de vraiment prendre
quelqu'un et éviter de traverser j'ai
peur pour vous quand vous traversez pas
aux jeunes ne pas se conduire l acompte
en cours tu dois rien les mecs c'est un
truc bizarre de parler à lui a parlé
ça
c'est mais heureusement plus bas dans la
dore elle vient de dire la bataille
lundi 1 juin l'iphone en commun
c'est quand même énorme alors isabelle
morini-bosc robien aller où mais elle
sait qu'elle doit revenir au moins 60
jours on discute elle dispute
merci alors bon on va dire que c'est
gagné